around different schemes and flares but  he came in and did a great job to get a  great coach and doc his Hawaiian Hoxton  on the jump shot  welcome to the family Kawhi Leonard  knocks down his first bucket as a  flipper there was an audible gasp when  he came out on the floor a lot of people  here did not expect him to play and now  it comes away with a leather larceny  back the other way to see right away  when it left the hands what has started  are the deep tries no count below  soaring over California montrezl harrell  slams it in with two with the best  system it's the best thing about it  because every effort Claire has this get  those restrictions right from a CO so  you can't shoot three when when world  water went down with it in just in an  injury the warning is that 11 a game was  plus me to the year before  Kawhi Leonard by the way